folks this week I've got gas okay so
here's a little news story that you may
not have heard this week President Obama
wants Congress to quickly pass an
unconditional of the federal gasoline
tax I read this article at foxnews.com
as tax is set to expire at the end of
this government's fiscal year on
September 30th the tax has been 18 point
4 cents per gallon since 1993 annually
amounting to about 32 billion dollars
which is then given back to the states
for road services repair etc now some
conservatives in Congress think this tax
should be cut and liberal is not a break
for big oil no no no no no no that's not
what I'm saying
but the state's believe that they should
be allowed to determine how to best
allocate these resources a few
interesting points here so please stay
with me and follow me on down the golden
money trail those little people make me
uneasy
and I make no apologies for it ok 1
listen I'm not a huge fan of oil
companies but you know who I like even
less the federal government now where I
was raised in Montreal we'd often pay
over 2 times the price you would pay for
gas here in the States at its peak gas
prices were so high for so long and
people were complaining about the big
oil companies at gas stations finally
started putting up pie charts to show
you where the money actually goes those
charts looks like this the government
was taking well over a 30% Chuck these
charts were way of gas stations saying
hey you think we're rolling in the dough
here you go you try running an honest
profit margin when 1/3 is skimmed off
the top which brings me to point to what
does this mean for the consumer not only
higher gas prices but more expensive
milk toilet paper bananas bottled water
and anything else who would ever have to
be transported to our ungrateful selves
it also likely results in higher
unemployment because small businesses
will tell you that they have to make
cutbacks in order to be able to
transportation costs folks these things
don't just show up to your house running
on magic beans and happy thoughts number
three the term Big Oil is thrown around
so frequently that you actually have
people believing that elections are
bought and sold by these companies again
not a huge fan of the
but if we're being honest here's a chart
showing you the top list of donors from
1989 to 2010 surprise Big Oil's nowhere
to be found nor the Koch brothers but at
least 10 of the top 15 our union
affiliated and guess where all of their
money goes which brings me to point
number 4 for if this bill is not renewed
as conservatives would want not only
would it give the states more mobility
in allocating resources but it would
allow them to avoid federal regulations
requiring them to hire union workers on
their highway projects by that same
token if the status quo remains the same
however public sector unions will
continue to remain employed and enjoy
the kind of job security that you and I
could only ever dream of having
regardless of job performance so when
you hear policies like this and people
want to tell you the elections are
bought and paid for don't jump the gun
and go straight to Big Oil or Big Pharma
think big unions
[Music]
you